hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna do a
video about the biggest questions I have
after the better call Saul Season 5
Finale season 5 just wrapped up and it
did a fantastic job of setting up the
sixth and final season it seems a little
crazy to say that in a prequel show
where we already know the ending to many
of the main characters stories that
there are a lot of burning questions I
want answers to before we get into them
this is your spoiler warning this video
is not something you'll want to watch if
you aren't caught up with better call
Saul through the season 5 finale and the
entire run of Breaking Bad and El Camino
you've been warned
better call Saul season 5 started out
doing what was expected after Jimmy
McGill got his license to practice law
reinstated at the end of season 4 he
officially changed his name to Saul
Goodman and using the contacts he built
up selling burner phones started his new
practice in criminal law
he wasn't exactly the guy we knew from
Breaking Bad yet but all the pieces were
in place for him to get there while he
was doing this his partner Kim Wexler
was by his side and while he was dipping
into this new world kim was continuing
on her path of a budding legal career
she'd built up the biggest question
everyone had was what is gonna happen to
Kim we don't learn much about Saul's
personal life during the Breaking Bad
series but he doesn't seem like the same
guy as when Kim's in his life the
general assumption is that she's just
not around anymore at that time by the
end of season 5 things have changed Kim
and Jimmy got married Jimmy went to work
for the cartel doing a job for them he
got stranded in the desert after being
caught in a shootout which was a really
violent scene that had a major effect on
him and during his time away in an
attempt to figure out what was going on
Kim made herself known to his cartel
client so in the season finale we saw a
different side of Kim where she presents
this idea of going after Howard Hamlin
so they can advance the Sandpiper
settlement which will get Jimmy about
two million dollars so the biggest
question I have after season 5 is what's
going on with Kim after the season 5
finale when I was working on my recap
video I wasn't entirely sure about Kim's
motivations in bringing up the idea of
going after Howard they got to that
point in a roundabout way first Jimmy
gives a half-hearted attempt to separate
from Kim in order to protect her she
senses that he's going in that direction
and she tries to fix the situation over
dinner they're just sort of playfully
talking about what happened with Howard
at the courthouse and how they could do
something to get back at him and that
progresses until Kim brings up this big
idea so that's where the confusion comes
in did this start off innocently enough
she was just trying to be there for her
partner bring him out of this funk where
he wants to leave or is this an idea
that she's had and she was just waiting
for the right moment to spring it Rhea
seehorn who plays Kim and Bob Odenkirk
who plays Jimmy McGill did a great
interview on Entertainment Weekly's
website and the takeaway from that is
that we're not supposed to know their
final scene where she walks away from
the bed and he looks a kind of stunned
and she does the finger guns
that's all very intentional so the
question is what does it all mean
does it mean in that moment that Kim has
just decided to break bad or is it
pointing out the fact that there's more
under the surface that we just don't
know about Kim's past the next question
I would have is what will Lalo do next
he survived this attempt on his life he
lost people that he cared about in that
he was probably able to buy himself a
little bit of time in having the
assassin called the middleman and tell
him the job was done we have to imagine
that we'll get out to Gus and for a
little while at least he'll think that
Lalo is dead I think he's going to
figure out that it was Gus right away I
mean he told the guy that he knew who
hired him and I think he's saying Gus
when he says that that's who he's butted
heads with and so what would his next
move be I think it's reasonable to
expect that he's gonna return to
Albuquerque and I also think that it's
reasonable that he's gonna look up Jimmy
and Kim and they're gonna be part of
whatever he's planning and I'm guessing
this attempt on his life is gonna take
that cold war that he's been in with Gus
and make it into a hot one and that's
pretty crazy to think about
speaking of Gus another big question I
have is are we gonna learn what happened
in Chile we heard a couple of mentions
of Santiago this season and we had the
return of hair Schuler and so I am
guessing that we'll learn some answers
about Gus's history the next question I
had
is there any chance for nacho to get out
of this I mean the first part is can he
get out of Mexico can he get himself
away from lawless Hacienda it seems
pretty unlikely there is a possibility
that there are vehicles or a driver that
were left behind after the assassins
were killed otherwise he's gonna get
hunted down by Lalo and then the
question becomes is he more valuable to
Lalo alive when he finds out that he has
connections to Gus we've always wondered
if nacho was gonna be able to get his
dad out alive and now the question is
more of is nacho gonna live to see
another day another big question I have
is how much time will pass in season six
at this point we know for certain that
there's more than four years until the
two shows timelines overlap we always
assume that better call Saul would end
right before the events of Breaking Bad
started or there would be considerable
overlap of the timelines at the end of
better call Saul where we're at now that
doesn't seem nearly as important as it
used to
as mentioned all the pieces are in place
for Jimmy to be the Saul character the
only thing that's left is his
relationship with Kim now that she's
made a turn and they're going to be
doing something big together it really
makes me wonder if there's gonna be a
big time jump or if it's gonna end and
then that is when the time jump would
happen I'm not considering Jean in that
at all though because Jean is a whole
different question how much time do we
actually think we're gonna spend with
Jean that's another assumption that fans
have had was that in wrapping up Jean
story which I definitely think they'll
do a lot of fans thought that they would
have full jean episodes that take place
in that timeline at this point what
happens to Jean is one of the biggest
mysteries left to answer I don't think
they can do that in a single teaser at
the beginning of the season nor would it
make sense to answer that question at
the beginning of the season in most
scenarios so will there be a lot of Jean
time or is that something they can just
wrap up in a couple of short sequences
when we talk about timelines and how
much time is going to pass another
question I would have is will season six
have any major cameos from Breaking Bad
characters I think there's a distinct
possibility that they might bring Hank
and Gomi back their connection to crazy
eight Crazy Eights connection to the
cartel story there's definitely room to
bring them in in a meaningful way most
people wonder if Walter White or Jesse
Pinkman will show up I'm not really sure
the showrunner Peter Gould has said on
numerous occasions since El Camino came
out it took the pressure off better call
Saul in other words it didn't need to
show them because they had one more
scene in El Camino he brings up two
important points and I think this is how
they'll decide the first is they're
telling the story of Jimmy's
transformation so if using Jesse or Walt
would serve that story then they would
think about doing it in other words
they're not really thinking about
bringing them in for just a passing
cameo the other thing he seems to
mention is that how busy those two
actors are and even if they wanted to do
it it may not be possible so I think
it's actually pretty unlikely that Walt
and Jesse will show up but I would still
love to see it and I know people say oh
it's just fanservice if it's a random
cameo but I would still probably jump up
from my chair and cheer if I saw them
pull up at the car wash and we just see
Walt doing his thing working there that
said I do think we'll see more cameos
from Breaking Bad characters they always
seem to have a couple the only one that
I think is really essential would be
Kuby he's an important character in
Saul's story and Breaking Bad I think
they wanted him to come back this season
but they weren't able to make it work
when Kim and Jimmy hired Stephen augs
character they mentioned that they had
written that scene for a different actor
who wasn't available so they had to
adjust it I think that would have been
Patrick cou B's introduction in the
better call Saul timeline but Bill burr
wasn't available to take the job beyond
that I can't think of anybody essential
to Saul story but let me know in the
comments who you'd like to see even if
it's a really minor Breaking Bad
character that they haven't used and so
the biggest question is what's gonna
happen between Jimmy and Kim I did a
whole video of the possible outcomes as
far as Kim not being in the story
anymore not much has changed I guess the
idea of her getting arrested for
whatever they plan to do to Howard looks
a lot more possible also she
might be of use to Lalo and whatever
plan he hatches it seems like the actors
and interviews went to this idea that we
don't really know Kim's backstory quite
a lot it could be that they're generally
interested in that in the same way that
we are you can't imagine that they would
be throwing it out there if it was
something they knew for certain but they
do know more about these characters than
we do from portraying them so I think we
will be learning a lot more about that
in season six but it's hard to say if
that has an impact on how she's going to
leave I'm really glad that they decided
to make Howard the target of this it
keeps that side of the story alive one
of the best things that season 5 did was
bring all the stories together and when
she quit Mesa Verde it almost felt like
the lawyer side of the story was just
not going to be important anymore
Plus Howard keeps the connection with
Chuck in the mix and Jimmy's inability
to deal with his death even though his
latest trauma from the shootout has
taken center stage
Chuck's death still haunts Jimmy Howard
being in the story keeps that viable as
a pressure point for him so I'm glad
that's there and I'm definitely curious
to see what they cook up and for Kim I'm
curious to know how long she's been
thinking about doing something like this
I don't think she's trying to scam Jimmy
out of the money that's something I saw
a lot of in the comments that people
thought that she was playing a long game
that seems like a little bit of a
stretch but what's great about where
we're at right now is we really don't
know for four seasons the mystery was
how does this guy Jimmy McGill who is
generally good hearted but is also a con
man who even when he tries to play it
straight has a propensity to cut corners
and bend the rules how does this guy
become no ethics style Saul Goodman now
the mystery is much more about Kim who
she is where she coming from with this
new direction and how is it gonna be the
wedge that gets between them or is it
just gonna be a temporary setback is
what they're getting into now with
Howard is that just gonna sideline the
relationship we do have that mention of
a phone call that Saul talks to
Francesca about in that flash forward to
the Breaking Bad timeline so they may
have to split up whether she's on the
run whether she's locked up and if
that's the case and there's always a
chance they might come back together
obviously a lot of people want to see
that happen in the Jean timeline
and you know what's crazy is that we are
gonna find out this is the last season
coming up and I do think they're gonna
answer those questions so let me know
what your questions are in the comments
we probably have some time to kill
between now and when the next season
comes out so what are you thinking about
what do you want to see happen please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon